okay well we'll make us Starks we've got
quite a lot to get free so welcome to my
talk
against a distracted world my name is
Steve the Hunts I'm a Microsoft MVP so I
write code like most people in the room
I also run a training company so I go
around teaching workshops both the
conferences and companies or private
companies and I'm also an offer for pool
science I don't got promised our
subscription in here yep you're all my
friends so I've got 21 courses up on
Provo site and hoping to grow that this
year so I want to starts off with a
quote from one race famous openings from
a book ever written by Charles Dickens A
Tale of Two Cities so it was the best of
times it was the worst of times it was
the age of wisdom it was the age of
foolishness now this book was written a
very long time ago it's about
yes about tragedy written during the
French Revolution but when we take this
opening line and apply it to our modern
day it feels scarily relevance so it was
the best of times you know we're living
in this age of technology we have the
Internet's we have computers that are
incredibly fast more programming
languages in the shake a stick at
including JavaScript frameworks now we
can pretty much do anything we want
creatively now with the tools that we
have available to us but also it's the
worst of times because with this rising
technology we have a hell of lots of
things that can distract us from you
know things like Netflix Amazon Prime
YouTube social media we're gonna talk a
lot about social media today so it's
lots of things out there they're all
vying for our attention they call it the
attention economy that's that's natural
word that they've given to it you know
these companies are trying to steal your
attention so that you engage with their
platforms so I wanted to talk kind of
why this is important this talk is
largely based around my own experiences
and some things I've had to grapple with
myself some things I've screwed up and
got wrong and the things I've got out of
balance so I'm talking about you know a
personal story things I've had to do
things I've fixed and hopefully you can
take some stuff away from it that might
help you as well so a little bit of
backstory so in 2017 in July I quit my
job which seems to shock everyone in the
office I just walked into my boss's
office handed him a letter and said I'm
going and me and my wife had planned
this for about a year so yeah we
the prototype stuff is doing quite well
we put you know a date in the diary and
if I hit certain milestones and targets
then I could quit and do this full-time
squeaky floorboards like what's
hilarious is I had not long turned 40 so
all of my friends like getting in touch
with me in that Steve you okay you'd
like your tone fourteen then you just
quit your job are you having a midlife
crisis people generally thought I was
having a crisis but I wasn't it was a
planned a planned activity and it is
fantastic so I no longer had a boss
standing over my shoulder you know
telling me what to do and it gave me a
lot of personal freedom which is
fantastic now you know we saw back in
the picture
no here that was that was my workspace
at home for quite a few months my wife
also works from home she has been for 16
years so I couldn't really fix her out
at the office upstairs so I moved into
the dining room temporarily as must it
was set up it was great but after a
while I started thinking wow you know
let's get we have a change of scenery
let's go into the lounge we'll just pop
some ink on Netflix while I'm working
no I was working I wasn't slacking off I
was writing scripts with all the stars
you know doing slides and all that good
stuff but then before I knew it I've
done 10 seasons of Big Bang Theory what
the hell yeah how can I sit here every
day on the sofa with my laptop working I
was being productive but there are the
ten seasons a Big Bang Theory is
ridiculous and it wasn't doing my back
and my posture any good but also I found
that working from home which generally
is people dream it's about to work from
home and work for mates I found that
after nine months I started to get cabin
fever now you're in the same place every
day you're working you know you've got
deadlines your stuff you're trying to do
then you have to go out and pick the
kids up they come home you guys do their
homework they want it to play with them
but then you're constantly thinking oh
I've got to get this stuff done even
though I had quite a wide deadline on
all the work I do you think to yourself
I need to get this done it kind of
starts affecting you a bit I was getting
to the point where it's actually
resenting being at home which is a
ridiculous thing because your home is
you know the place that you go is kind
of you the place you go for safety isn't
it it's your house
I was actually resenting being there a
bit because I starting to feel quite
stressed and anxious about the work I
had to do
and the fact that I felt arch is always
confined within these walls so that
point I thought okay let's look for a
co-working space so I found a co-working
space fairly close to me just ten
minutes on the train hired a fixed desk
you know that was my desk in the
co-working space fixed desk means you
know what's its co-working that is your
desk so you can leave your leave your
own kit on it
what did that for a while and what I
came to realize is that even though you
know I was living the dream working for
myself do my own thing what I was
actually missing was routine know the
routine of getting up hitting shower
taking the kids to school going to work
doing a hard day's work and then coming
home so for me I was kind of missing
that so after a while you know I worked
in the co-working space for about six
months and then an opportunity for
private office at the same site turned
up so got myself my own office my own
little man cave there it is
I love working there got all my stuff in
there you know miles there I started
going through so quite a long period of
sort of self-reflection around how am I
going to make my business successful how
am I going to be able to carry on doing
what I'm doing make it sustainable and
try to avoid my biggest fear which is
going back and get a proper job again
which is that what I don't want to do
and this has led me so do quite a lot of
thinking quite a lot of speaking written
books and courses on various subjects
around what we're talking today so what
I want to talk about is a bit about
distraction and procrastination and I
know
Lars covered this a little bit in his
talk prior to mine I'll talk about
social media addiction my particular
poison was Facebook I was chronically
addicted to using Facebook it's
ridiculous you the kids do something
funny you take a picture in the first
thought that goes through your mind is
let's upload this to Facebook kind of
stupid when you look back at it and talk
about self motivation and kind of you
know the importance of worrying about
things that you can control and I'm
going to go through my pretty much my
complete productivity and time
management toolbox some stuff in there
might be obvious and you know already
some stuff you might not be so well then
it might be useful for you what I don't
want you to think is that this is a talk
about me hating on technology because
it's not absolutely love technology you
know I spend a lot of time going to
conferences talking about software
development about how technology can
prove an
sometimes that balance can get out of
alignment and it can cause you some
problems so when I tested some of this
material on test audience part the
feedback cause I need to be careful that
you don't come across as being too
preachy so the first thing I did was I
went on Shutterstock and looked up a
picture of a vicar so I thought let's
put this put a little picture in here so
I'm not trying to preach to you I'm not
telling you what to do and it's taught
this is kind of the stuff that I've
dealt with and you know stuff that I've
done some of you may find useful some of
it you may think actually just doesn't
really apply to me
but thanks for telling this anyway but
I'm not here to tell you what to do I
don't have the right to do that that's
not what this is about so first of all
let's just talk a little bit about
distraction and procrastination so
procrastination is basically where you
have some work to do but you'd rather do
anything else but that work you know
here's a definition of it so the habit
of putting off or delaying especially
something requiring immediate attention
now procrastination has an evil twisted
half brother called procrustean this is
where you do stuff that you disguise as
work thinking that it's important but
actually or just putting off a bigger
task so for example you've got a
deadline that your boss is expecting
uses delivery one you have to fix a bug
maybe and then Scott Hanselman releases
a new blog post you think all about go
read that less importance my job it's
not actually going to get your bug fixed
and get you to where you need to be but
you disguise it as work we all do this
is anyone do this yeah quite a lot of
honesty that's good so crow Craster
working is the evil twisted half-brother
of procrastination there's lots of
different dangers to procrastinating
stops you achieving your goals now if
you have a goal that you want to do but
you keep doing something else like
watching YouTube or you know watching
umbrella Academy on Netflix which is
amazing by the way if you've not seen it
I'm not gonna take the same stance as
Lars where you have to cut all TV outs
I'm a little bit more liberal on
television than that but procrastinating
stops you from acting it stops you doing
the things that you need to do to
achieve and grow as a person and you
know professionally it stops you from
challenging yourself because when you
procrastinate you generally tend to do
the bare minimum to get the work done
typically you do that bare minimum
right at the last minute which also
increases your stress and anxiety levels
which in modern society you don't really
need more stress in your life but
procrastination does does do that
various different reasons why we
procrastinate I think these are kind of
some of the four big ones so one of them
is a fear of failure so if your boss
asks you to do some work and it maybe
it's something you've not done before
and you don't want to look like an idiot
in front of your peers by messing it up
that fear of failure can sometimes be a
bit debilitating especially has to do
something new some procrastinator x' are
perfectionists
so they don't want to turn something in
or you know release something until
they're absolutely you know over
confident or over happy that this thing
is perfect that quest for perfection can
lead you to delay the work that you're
working on or maybe not even started low
energy levels this is a big one you know
modern day you know we spend all day at
work we go home and watch TV we hang out
with friends we go to the gym whatever
we're constantly tired you know all of
us probably go to bed far too lazy that
moment space too and then have to wake
up early for work so we feel drained a
lot of the time and this you know
obviously leads to a lack of focus so
decreasing the chances of
procrastination there's a few simple
things you can do none of this stuff is
sort of rocket science or voodoo so
first one is accepting that you're not
perfect
you know you don't need to constantly be
looking for perfection all the time in
what you do most of the time good enough
is good enough yes as long as you feel
like you've done some good work you
don't have to polish everything
constantly you can actually iterate on
tasks failure is not fatal you know we
all make mistakes we all screw things up
the best thing about failure is actually
gives you something to learn on it's
kind of critical feedback on some work
that you've done again aim to be aim to
do your best and be happy with the
output you know just do something that
is good enough that you're happy with is
fine you can always go back and revisit
something later and then you know try to
develop a healthier lifestyle this is
easier said than done with a lot of us
and trust me I know you know going out
and being healthy
lots of exercise isn't always the thing
that's forefront on our minds but
actually trying to get a bit more
exercise you know drinking more water
and eating a better diet does actually
create energy levels and it increases
your mood levels as well you know with
that said going to bed earlier
he's obviously good she need more sleep
and this is probably the hardest time
for all of us but reducing your screen
time before bed or if you used suckering
setting on Apple devices they've got
that nighttime mode I'm pretty sure you
can get similar apps on Windows for
doing the same where kind of takes all
those blue hues out of the screen said
the screen looks warmer that actually
sort of helps and helps get you to sleep
apparently so that's procrastination I
don't want to spend too long on it
because typically whenever anyone does a
talk on productivity I tend to spend the
entire talk talking about
procrastination but that is really just
kind of the first tip of the iceberg one
of the big things I want to talk about
is controlling social media addiction
and if you're saying either I found
quite difficult and it's also one of the
biggest distractions I think we face in
the modern day now a bit of a
controversial slide but you know
addictions can take various different
forms you know alcohol smoking social
media drugs gambling anything that gives
us those kind of you know chemical
boosts in our brain to make us feel
better can become an addictive trait and
social media is no difference in that
and forever
you're constantly we've seen people just
constantly buried with our heads in
there on that you know the screens are
their phones and I've got the Train down
on Tuesday also but sitting on the tube
I'm going to the hotel I looked around
the train carriage I think I saw two
people reading an actual paper book
remember them and everyone else had just
you know facedown on their phones nobody
was talking to each other it's just
constant you know scrolling with with
their thumbs I'm pretty sure the next
stage of evolution we're gonna have you
know much stronger thumbs now one of the
problems with social media is it's all
about how social media and addictions is
about how it affects the chemical
balances in your brain and there's
various different neurotransmitters
which are part of this so the first one
and the one that we probably hear the
most about is dopamine so that's
you're a transmitter for reward
reinforcement and pleasure so basically
when you post something on social media
and someone clicks like or a load of
people click like or they start
retweeting your posts makes you feel
good you get a little hit of dopamine
colors are the buttons and icons on
social media sizes should they've put a
lot of research into what are the best
colors to show you when when you click
like on something to make that dopamine
hit larger yeah it has a similar effect
to a drug or alcohol so quick fix to
that is try and get your dopamine
rewards from something else so I don't
know about you but whenever I work on
some tasks I've got my little to-do list
you know whenever I complete a task and
I you know physically color that little
box in next to the task that makes me
feel good that kind of gives you a
little dopamine hits
exercise or going outside scene doing
something new like that gives you a
dopamine it's a replacement for social
media or even just finishing a good book
so the other day I you know just
finished reading Neil Gaiman some Norse
mythology book fantastic book felt great
when I finished reading it so melatonin
this is a hormone that governs your
circadian rhythm and your sleep-wake
cycle so how many of you have been
working on something late at night you
know that there's a bug in your personal
project you just want to get it fixed
you get there and then you go to bed and
your brain is just like but you can't
get to sleep you know it it affects the
amount of melatonin I'm going around
your body and it because your brain is
just active it means you can't get to
sleep and you end up having a rubbish
night of broken sleep can you feel awful
in the morning various different ways in
which you can bring balance your
melatonin in your body is getting
sunshine near that actual outdoor
balling big flaming ball of death which
we can't really see at the moment I'm
sure it will come out at some point this
year sunshine and the vitamins that
produces helps regulate melatonin in
your body again avoiding screens late at
night if we can or at least using a a
nighttime mode on your screen a warm
bath or a shower before bed
you know so everyone can realize or
appreciate that probably relaxes you
quite a bit looking at having a good
soak in the bath and something I've
started doing or getting back into habit
of is reading for at least half and
before going to sleep I find that just
helps knock me out
not because it's a boring book it just
kind of helps relax you so deaf one is
oxytocin so this is a neurotransmitter
that affects your social interaction so
sexual chemistry bonding between family
and friends saying that even if you
class yourself as a you know rule devout
introverts you still need human contact
from time to time and you know you get
oxytocin released through social
interactions where you actually go and
physically meet people like we all are
now hugging and kissing consensual
obviously then just go around hugging
and kissing anyone cuz I'll get you in
trouble now virtually interactions you
know any you know somehow become friends
on Facebook with the person that bullied
you at school but then how am I going
into that situation but you know
virtually interactions they do give you
a little oxytocin boost but I think like
actually going out if your friends you
know spending time with your kids you
know going for a you know a dinner date
with your partner go into the pub with
your friends or going to play squash or
someone that kind of physical
interaction is so much more powerful
when you just don't get that through
virtual interactions so the quick fix is
actually go out and meet people you know
close the lid on your laptop actually go
out and do something doesn't have to be
all the time or constant you know just
going out for a coffee with some friends
at lunchtime or going for a walk playing
with the kids you know saying I'm
finding very rapidly I've got two
children four daughters 11 this year my
son's 8 where the hell is that time gone
they're growing up so quickly me and my
daughter starts high school this year so
she's getting to that age where she's
not really gonna want to know me that
much because I'm just gonna embarrass
her so yeah if you do have children you
need to make sure you use that time
wisely because they grow up bloody fast
yeah you know real conversations or a
physical contact it's important now the
fine point of science you gonna do is
serotonin so this is neurotransmitter
that contributes the feeling of
happiness and well-being so high levels
of this you know boosting mood make you
feel happy and energetic low levels is
of this can be linked to depression and
lethargy you know sometimes when you
wake up in the morning you just feel a
bit like
fitting a bit down today well I do want
to caveat though is that just feeling a
bit down in the dumps from time to time
is a completely different thing from
clinical depression
I'm not classing clinical depression in
this because I'm not qualified to talk
about that at all I'm talking about more
we're you know generally you're quite a
happy person but you know sometimes you
feel a bit down in the dumps it's
normally a low level of serotonin in
your body this ain't these quite a big
facts I'm going to touch on a bit more
in a moment is this social media can
actually affect your self-worth you know
you get people just constantly posting
happy pictures all the time you're just
bombarded with other people with fake
happiness you can actually sort of
affects how you feel personally about
your own life
so again serotonin and sunshine I would
say exercising sunshine helps with that
trying to maintain a positive outlook
now this is why I'm put that caveat
about clinical depression in there cuz
the last person you ought to say to
someone who is clinically depressed and
being treated for it is you know be more
positive I'm not saying that at all this
is more about when you're just feeling a
bit low from time to time and that glass
is half-full damn it so I wrote an
article a fairly lengthy article on this
on my blog if a long URL should have
probably done a bitly link but a little
quote from it here so social media is
dangerous because it rewards you for
posting and getting likes dopamine it
makes you feel artificially connected
oxytocin and even if you are isolated
and deep in isolated deep inside it
makes you feel bad about yourself
so atoning as you vicariously live the
life through others or you live the life
of your friends yeah by constantly
looking at all the points at photos they
post and this is quite a big one because
when you post stuff on Facebook or
Instagram or Twitter or whatever your
social media platform of choice is
apparently tick-tocks a thing according
to my daughter if people don't generally
post about the bad stuff that goes on in
their lives
people have bad things happen or you
know stuff that's not great but
generally when people post on social
medias all the good things so you
playing with the kids on the beach or
you've gone out partying with your
friends if you've got hundreds of
friends on Facebook and you just or
Instagram you just got a constant
barrage of people doing really cool
stuff and then you're sitting at home
right you know in your pajamas you know
chin and deck on telly you know it can't
be kind of affects yourself worth of it
so how everyone else has these really
wonderful lives and I'm just sitting
here in my underpants watching TV
pajamas like pajamas and I think this is
a problem I found no problem I started
feeling that you know as I started using
Facebook more I'm gonna talk about how a
controlled Facebook in a moment but as I
started adding more people onto it yeah
you feel great to start with and then
it's something you hit this kind of
cliff edge I mean you start hurtling
down the other side you actually start
feeling really shitty about yourself
which is how I felt so I thought
something had to be done about this now
what I'm not saying is you should just
go and cut all social media out your
life that's not realistic a fad diets
don't work and yeah believe me I know
fat diets do not work okay
it's the same with social media just
cutting it out and getting rid of it
that's nice not practical no one's gonna
do that I'm not you're gonna try and
suggest it so I looked at my use of
social media and kind of how I will have
it integrates in my life and I kind of
split it into categories so these are
the four networks that I would typically
use now Facebook Instagram LinkedIn and
Twitter so I put them into categories so
all of my personal life family friends
all that sort of stuff it's purely gonna
be Facebook Instagram I'm not gonna let
my work life bleed into those ones my
professional life is gonna be more
around Twitter and Instagram so start
the start off with Facebook so I don't
know if anyone's over I had 750 friends
on Facebook what really and it was like
you know people from school from you
know 43 now so people when I was at like
genius school or on there which is
bizarre
the kids used to try and tie me to the
fence by my tie at high school
we're on there I can't quite remember
how that happened and you know I tried
going through an exercise or just going
through the list and might removing
people I'm not really gonna interact
with personally that's actually really
hard to do you think oh well there's my
mate Tracy is that timer resilient
Emery's you know that was a laugh you
know keep her on there you know you're
going through that you start thinking of
excuses about why you should keep people
on there and then when you get to the
bottom of the list you've only deleted
about 20 people
from the list which was kind of a
fruitless exercise so I came up with a
little process how cool do you stay or
do you go send in two little game so
first one their new CEO when I tried to
tame the list on Facebook No are you
family or close friends of course
they're gonna stay your family's family
your close friends your close friends so
close friends people are seeing the
actual real world people I go to the pub
with people I go for coffees wish and
then I thought well old co-workers I had
hundreds of old co-workers on there only
for which I actually get on with
personally like you know outside of
outside of work the rest were all
perfectly nice people pleasant people
got on with him well but once I've left
those companies was actually gonna see
them again or you know do anything with
them probably not it sounds harsh but I
wasn't gonna go out you know it's bad
say clubbing but I don't do that I'd go
into the pub or something like that and
then I thought well if you are on the
list and I saw you walking down the
street what would I do but I walk up to
you and go oh how you're doing this go
for coffee and ketchup order hide behind
phone box or quickly dive into Primark
to avoid you you know if it was that
situation it's probably no point having
you on Facebook yeah so I'm not gonna
want to hang around view me all right
yet the problems that can be really
horrible not people hating but I'm not
but you have to be realistic you can't
have that many social connections and
actually sort of make sense or meaning
out of it and in the final little were
little guard which I put around the
entire thing is I removed anyone that
was still on there that were complainers
or overly political now especially on a
day to day were poignant dates are they
like here anyone has a little pop and a
little complain or a little window on
social media no no and again I've done
it myself but you know I had some people
on there that I like that I get on well
with but they're constantly going on
about Breck she'll they're constantly
going on about Trump they guess
depressing after well if you've got lots
of people just going on about politics
constantly just makes you feel crap you
know times are harder the minute I mean
we've got brexit happening at 11:00 p.m.
tonight
you know things aren't amazing but I
don't want to see that constantly in my
feed because it's just depressing
so I use that as a way of removing
people when I got
750 friends down 250 people that I
actually you know love like care about
what to see in the real world and I
genuinely do care about what they post
on Facebook you know they've all got
family so you know that seemed like what
the kids are up to now because of that a
lot of these people don't actually post
that much on Facebook so I don't
actually check Facebook that much
anymore probably going a couple of times
a week to see what people are doing so
my facebook usage went from up here
right way down there and I'll still get
meaning from it I still enjoy using it
but I've just got it a little bit more
under control Twitter oh this is an
interesting when I've got a little work
little name that I call Twitter is the
toxic dumpster fire of hate that's an
actual picture of her Twitter server
after Scott Helms posted something it's
not in the room Izzy no thank you
touches an interesting one as a platform
as a concept and an ideas it's brilliant
you know I've talked about if I was
wearing a hat or doff my hat to the to
the inventors of it but you know when I
think you can scroll down a twitter feed
I've you've ever noticed how something
that can seem perfectly innocent we need
to start reading the comments just
descends into chaos and hates really
really quickly I mean you literally have
Twitter mobs going around after people
just looking for anything to complain
about and just basically attacking
people when it's absolutely horrible
really really horrible so I've you know
I used to use Twitter a fair amount not
as much as Facebook but I've kind of
changed the way I use it and some people
don't some people agree with it some
people don't but you know this is just
the way I dealt with it so I mostly use
Twitter now as a way of notifying people
about why the stuff I've done so I make
the assumption you know I've got to a
half thousand followers it's never
really gone up from that over the last
couple of years I assume most people are
there because they've now seen some of
my courses read my books seen me speak
so I assume they're there because they
want to know what I'm doing so I mostly
use Twitter just to let people know what
I'm doing it's a notification hub as far
as I'm concerned if people don't like
that they can do some follow me it's
fine I'm not gonna be offended somehow I
was following 3,700 people because I go
to a lot of conferences and you know you
see a speaker that you like and
their Twitter handles on a thing only
just follow who follow follow follow
follow constantly few years he just
constantly follow him
I ended up with 3,700 people so when I
actually look at my Twitter timeline it
was just absolute mess of stuff from
people that I don't know and all their
conversations start descending into like
height and as people I'll give him of
each other it's horrible so I went
through I just did no the process was
quite simple sigh do I actually know who
you are and if I seen you in person
before if the answer is yes and I kept
them on there and then I just removed
ones I didn't tell me personal not being
a whole wall gets images what's the
point of having people on there that you
don't know I'm probably the last person
to make use of this by I started using
lists more on Twitter so you can set
lists of different people up which is
quite useful so you know I've got one
for my speaker friends that you know I
travel around the world with I've got
you know famous authors I've you know
people have Neil Gaiman Margaret Atwood
people whose opinions I'd like to read
about and care about I've got another
one of celebs you know I personally care
what Dwayne the rock Johnson's up to
everyday he's the best actor ever in my
in my view and then I started thinking
about wait is there some tools I can use
to make Twitter kind of work for me more
in my business I know a lot of people
use things like tweet that but someone
introduced me to one called later or
later calm which is quite an interesting
at all it basically gives you like a an
Outlook style calendar and you can just
schedule when you want stuff to go out
and you don't even have to log into
Twitter anymore you just schedule all
these tweets up and off they go and then
you use buffer you know if you read an
interesting ask or anything
oh that's relevant saying I'm doing I'll
just have that retweeted you just use
buffer to schedule the posts so a lot of
time I just don't even lock into Twitter
anymore and if I do it's normally to see
what the rocks up to Instagram I've
never really had a problem of Instagram
to be fair I enjoy using it but I don't
use it that often and I haven't got that
many people that I follow on it's it's
mostly family and friends so I didn't
really feel like I had to tame Instagram
that wasn't really a problem for me
Facebook was the big one for me so I
didn't really do anything with that and
LinkedIn or LinkedIn LinkedIn it's not I
don't really see why I'd need to
is that everyday again I'm notify people
about books and blog posts and all of
that
generally if I'm an event and some of
these two connects with me I just send
them to LinkedIn because you know that's
where you have professional connections
so again everybody had a problem with
that one because I don't really use it
that much
now the other change I started doing was
I've basically deleted all social media
from my phone so I've got no social
media apps on my phone at all and I've
them on my tablet there everything's
available on my tablet if I need it or I
can use it from my laptop I'm a desktop
computer but if I'm out and about on my
phone I don't want to be you know
putting my phone out and seeing what's
going on on Twitter I just don't care
you know I can do that when I'm back at
the house or the office oh that felt
really weird to start with because you
kind of have this muscle memory where
you just reach down to pick your phone
up and check it and it's like well the
station I think really check on my phone
because I've deleted all the apps so
that worked quite well for me now the
thing with the internet and social media
stuff about the thing that she scared
she told me the most he's kind of how my
children and I start dealing with this
stuff so my daughter's you know she's
and I each now where she likes to play
games like roblox and she has a laptop
she plays roblox on it and she's got an
iphone next to her doing a FaceTime
group FaceTime chat of all of her
friends at the same time you know she's
starting to get to the age of being
aware of the internet and the things you
can do with it my son's similar you know
he simply plays roblox and he's you know
big into Minecraft so kind of how their
usage of the Internet is going to evolve
over time that's actually worrying me as
a parent is it worried anyone else's
parent or guardian yeah quite you know
quite a few hands going on and I think
it is a problem so me and my wife
actually sort of took some drastic
action with the kids last year I told
some people there's no that's a
brilliant idea
tell some other people you think are you
really horrible but it works quite well
so most modern routers let you do
banhammer indexable so what you can do
is you can go into your routes a log on
page you can select devices individually
and you can set time restrictions up for
those devices so my kids devices they
they use they've got time windows where
it only works but it's also got a button
abandon button so you can just cut off
their internet connection
so what me and my wife do now and it was
hard for about two weeks until the kids
sudden
clicked and slightly forming new habits
but in the morning the kids cannot have
any internet access until they get up
they get dressed in their school
uniforms they brush their teeth and they
ready to go to school have their
breakfast and do half an hour of reading
in fun with me or my wife once it done
that yeah no they've got about half an
hour 40 minutes for me to leave for
school they can go play on the internet
for a little bit when they get home from
the school Internet's disabled so they
have to do their homework that's the
half an hour I've read in and make sure
sure they've rooms tidy now this was a
big one for us because I sons got ADHD
so getting him to actually focus on
anything he's a hundred times harder
than getting a normal seven-year-old to
focus on anything but we started seeing
gradual change in his behavior because
he wants to play Minecraft he wants to
play roblox so we'll get in and
literally put on taking my shoes off
he's standing there if he's reading
record in his homework book you say
let's get it done
which is good Jamie allowed to have a
cup of coffee first but you know we'll
work with it so I'm not saying everyone
should do this because this is kind of
works really well for us it actually
helps reinforce some new habits into the
children so thank you might want to
consider if you've got one of those
admin pages on the Rita
okay so self motivation so a lot the
time in our busy stressful lives it can
be quite difficult to actually sort of
feel motivated to do work all the time a
motivation kind of the court falls into
two categories so you have intrinsic
motivation which is when in an internal
desire motivates you to do something so
you're motivated so work on that little
pet project because you want to do it
it's going to help you learn any
technology that's an intrinsic motivator
an extrinsic motivator is when your
motivation come to an external source ie
you've got your boss micromanage and
you're standing behind your chair
constantly asking you is it done yet how
are you doing now that's an extrinsic
motivator and when we talk about
motivation there's a term that's used
which isn't commonly use but it's called
the locus of control was anyone heard of
the locus of control before and they're
only a couple of hands and this is quite
important
so the locus of control is the capacity
to which you believe you have complete
control and power over what happens in
your life and you can think of it as
kind of like a spectrum so we have the
external locus of control and the
internal locus of control at the
external is you think your achievements
are outside of your control determines
by fate and independence of your hard
work or decisions so as an example we
think that I've just completed this big
piece of work but the only reason I
completed it was because Sara did this
for me and George did that and Bob did
this it's not because you did it it's
because of all these other things that
you're saying contributed to that
success your internal locus of control
is achievements that there are within
your control and you determine them by
your hard work or decisions so this is
where you think I see I you know
completed this piece of working is
because I've put the effort in it was me
that did this another way of thinking
about this is it's about worrying about
what you can personally control day to
day so as an example I'll put the first
one on there deliberately just because
of what today is about
so things I can't control brexit kind of
control brexit well we had the
opportunities of votes fetch opportunity
to have an election last year but apart
from that can I do I have any control or
influence over what's going to happen
over next you know so I'm not gonna
worry about it I'm gonna try and make it
work as well as I can for you know my
family and alright well I can't control
it so I'm not going to fret over it a
lot of people fret over it the passing
of time the one thing we cannot control
you know time is ticking it's constantly
you know progressing I'm not gonna worry
too much about that I can't control time
I haven't invented a time machine yet so
I'm not gonna worry about it so I'm just
gonna try and make the best use of my
time what other people think or do I
can't control what other people think I
can't control too much whether you enjoy
this talk or not so I hope you do but
you know that's kind of outside of my
control I can't force you to like what
I'm saying and you know we Brits or a
lot of us Brits so the weather we can't
control that unfortunately what I would
like to see
things I can control so how I approach
deadlines if I have a deadline for
Pluralsight course no I've signed a
contract that I had to deliver on time
that's what we might control to do that
I think about how I'm gonna pace the
work and then I'm gonna deliver stuff
that's within my control to sort out the
happiness of children they're not my
kids they just stop photos but the
happiness of my children that's within
my control I have to make time to play
with them watch films of them play Lego
play Minecraft and you know take them
out as we might control weight and
health yeah breathing at this point that
is within my control I'm not saying I
control that very well but it is within
my control and again who you follow well
social media no we talked at length
about that but that is within your
control your social media profile is
your place you control who you bring
into it okay so what want to sort of
focus on an XP is kind of lots of focus
productivity and different time
management tools there's all things I
use you know I took a long critical look
at how I work how I sort get stuff done
I'd like to think I'm fairly productive
you know I've done twenty-one PROSITE
courses I've written nine books and I do
lots of talks and workshops so I'm I
think I'm pretty good at managing my
time now after that a squeeky stage
after that time at the beginning of me
working for myself where kind of things
went a bit wrong I think I've kind of
got a good handle on it now so some of
these gonna be a fairly obvious you know
drink more water this stuff is actually
good for you and doesn't really cost
that much if you take it out of the tap
but you'll be surprised you know if you
wake up in the morning and drink you
know a large glass of water before you
do anything else and then just sip water
throughout the day that's gonna
constantly that's going to keep you
energized an alert and help you focus
more on your work the dehydration is
saying that creeps up when you face Bowl
quite quickly and you don't necessarily
know you're dehydrated and that can
affect your focus and your ability to
work on something game is touched on
this already but I wanted to include
this picture cuz I really like it so
getting plenty of sleep very important
regular exercise I'm not saying you have
to become a gym bunny or you know
pretend you're mr. motivator than the
bums leg my science treatment but
because that is not me the people that
were old enough in the room remember
here mr. motivators
but yeah you don't have to do lots of
things I what I've been at this
conference you know I've taken the lifts
a few times but Germany I've taken the
stairs to go between floors it's just a
little bit of you know exercise it's not
much I do a lot of walking I live in a
small town called belper in the Peak
District National Park and it's very
hilly so I go out every day I do at
least an hour's walk in the morning
because it's quite hilly and at weekends
I go hiking a lot with family so whilst
I don't goes to the gym and pump iron or
anything like that
I do get quite a lot of regular exercise
out in the countryside
someone just fallen off a chair setting
goals Nano loves talked about this quite
a bit in this previous talk if anyone
was in that but setting goal which is
very important so how you be productive
and there's lots of different types of
goals you can have you know weekly goals
you know by Friday I want to have done
this I'm going to do by doing these
tasks you might have quarterly goals
things that you want to achieve
personally or professionally over the
next quarter and then you might have
sort of the longer-term yearly goals or
themes and I like to think in terms of
themes so as anyone heard of a podcast
called cortex with CGP grey and my curly
one personally it's a fantastic podcast
it's all about productivity and time
management and one of the things they do
in that you sort of doing news
resolutions they set yearly themes so
for example my themes this year are the
year of branching out you know I do a
lot of probably site of stuff I want to
do a lot of other stuff this year first
year of branching out the year of health
I'm trying to bring my weight down
gradually and get more exercise and you
know the year of growth you know I'm
running a business on top so you grow
the things so that I don't have to go
back and get a job to do lists and plans
every day are vitally important there's
two measures I do for my sort daily
planning so I use an app called todoist
you know one the list Microsoft to do
where we scored it all the same sort of
thing
I don't use those apps to track daily
tasks but I use them to track kind of
larger milestones so something like a
poolside course you know I know I need
to write the script by this day I need
to record module 1 by this state so on
and so on you know I need to submit
everything by this state
write all the questions by this states
and submit everything finally by the
state track higher level kind of tasks
in that and then I use a while an iPad
and a Apple pencil by using an app
called good notes and I do physical
handwritten to-do lists every day cuz I
find by physically writing out by hand
it just kind of feels more real somehow
can't quite explain why because it's not
really much difference to using an app
by thing I find quite motivation is when
I write a task down I draw a little box
next to it when I completed that task
had to physically color the Box in feels
great when I do that new service be well
you know list of black splotches down
the page by actually planning what
you're gonna do in your day is really
important they're not all plans can be
followed through exactly because you
know stuff happens but you know trying
to plan it out at the start of the day
is very useful blocking out time in your
calendar is very effective as well I
mean even though I've worked by myself I
don't have any employees I still use my
calendar to block out time so I know
that you know I'm supposed to be working
on a course you know either these two
hours I need to do the accounts on this
hour and that kind of helps me just
prioritize and schedule what I'm going
to do previous companies I worked out
use updates this concept called core
hours where you know between 10 and 12
is complete focused work time and then
between 2 & 4 was exactly the same so
you close your email you turn your phone
off put your headphones on and just
focus in those two hours shooting four
hours of dedicated focus work a day and
then meetings emails and all the other
distractions can kind of happen in the
hours outside of that that works quite
effectively for me reward yourself for
hitting goals this is where mine and
Lars finking diverges a because he was
saying in his previous tool you know TV
is really really bad you should just not
watch TV I like watching TV I like my
Netflix account but I use it as a reward
so if I've worked really hard and I've
achieved thing
I want to do during the day I'm gonna
watch two episodes of umbrella Academy
in the evening or witcher i've got which
i lined up next so i think it's fine to
watch TV if you do as a reward obviously
the beginning I said - somehow - tracks
don't you watch ten seasons a big bang
theory that you know things are a bit
out of balance there but you know reward
yourself if you reward yourself by going
out for a walk after you've completed
some tasks that's great
a cup of coffee might be your reward or
you might want to go out with your
friends at the weekend as a reward for
doing you know hard week's work but make
sure you reward yourself don't forget to
do that so I do a lot of fair amount of
writing whether it's books or courses
you may do the same as well as you might
have to write reports or you know
extensive documentation the most
terrifying thing when you're trying to
do writing is having a blank page in
front of you and Wordle whatever word
processor you use they call it blank
page syndrome axes you know it's
intimidating now if I do a promo site
course it's about an hour and a half
long that's around 25,000 words which is
about a hundred page standard text and
standard paperback that's a lot of stuff
to write so the technique I use is
called outlining novel writers call it
plotting so if actually what I do is I
start out and I think what are my main
chapters or what are my main module
headings so I'll write those down you
can do them is like h1 level headings in
a document or you could use a mind
mapping tool and then I think more for
this chat so what are the main themes I
want to talk about so they become your
head into levels so you just need to put
those in there for each heading - you
think well what are the things I want to
talk about this particular subject well
might have some pros and cons on this
subject on that some personal feelings
so you just make brief notes and you do
that for the entire document and then
you go through and you do your research
so there's you know five websites or
blog articles which back up the points
on making so you just put the links to
those in the document so you've got the
morning one place and when I do this for
a course you know by the time I finish
the outline in process I've probably got
like a 1520 page document that's in note
form says exactly what I want this
entire piece to say once you've done
that and you've gone through that
process and that process can take a
while we can take me three or four weeks
when I'm doing a blow
psychos to build that up but when you've
done that you've done the hard work you
know what you're gonna be saying you
just have to sit down and write the
actual text to back it out and it
becomes much easier at that point
because you've broken the Popham down
and you've outlines the entire document
and you can then go and write it this is
the same you have to do reports or
documentation for systems as well does
anyone do outlining for documents
few people yeah it's really really
effective so novel writers call it
plotting it when you hear about novel
writers you hear about plotters and
pantses plotters are the people that
actually work out the plot beforehand
and pantses the people who just make it
up as they go along and there's
different styles but I do this flip side
to that is if you're working on a new
task if you're working on a big project
or you've been assigned a big task
sometimes you can feel a bit threatening
and you have to work on that task so you
want to break it down and then break it
down again and then break it down again
and then you've got a whole bunch of
tasks like you know file a new solution
you know check solution into github repo
at the initial class for doing it's out
of control if it is you break it down
into lots of little steps you take these
tiny little baby steps and then after a
while you've implemented a large part of
your project because I don't about you I
used to feel quite anxious about big
projects and you've got this big thing
in front of you but it's mountain to
climb but by breaking it down it just
really helps you get started this one's
very common I probably don't even need
to talk on this slide I can just show a
picture of a tomato timer probably
everyone knows not going to talk about
but focused work Sprint's are an
effective technique has anyone done
Pomodoro timing yeah quite a few people
this is where you have a time it doesn't
have to be a physical time and like that
it can be just on you stop on the phone
but you might work right you know
completely focused no distractions
headphones on you work your ass off for
twenty minutes then you take a five
minute break and then you repeat the
cycle and you might say that you know
for each hour I'm going to do two or
three well probably too focused work
Sprint's like this again it's a really
effective way of making you zero in on
what you're doing on focus you know you
have to turn your phone off lock your
phone away close your email close
anything that can distract you
and then just work solidly for those 20
minutes batching similar tasks together
is quite useful technique sake I wasn't
really aware off until someone pointed
it out to me and as I know yeah that
makes sense but if you're going to do
lots of different tasks throughout the
week and some of those tasks are similar
why don't you back them all together and
do them in one go she can so an example
for me you know I run a business you
know I have to photograph receipts I
have to tag financial transactions and
an accounting system how to do finance
reports for my accountant I tend to
battle those tasks together during the
week and typically I'll do those on a
Friday afternoon after lunch or I'm kind
of winding down ready for the weekend
I'll just kind of get some of the menial
stuff out of the way you know when I'm
working on qualities I tend to do all
the writing in one go I do all the
recording in one go I'll do all the
editing in one go because it by batch
entire stack every kind of keeps you
focus and you don't have to do this
constant contextual mind's switching
into different areas of work that's a
really useful technique if you can do
performing dreaded tasks in the morning
this is another thing I try and do if I
can I'm most motivated first thing in
the morning when I start work so if I
know I've got a really task I need
to get done the biggest way I'm gonna
succeed is by doing that first and
getting it out of the way and then use
some of the more fun tasks as a reward
for afterwards this one I do all the
time my inbox is an absolute disaster
zone so every quarter I declare email
bankruptcy so if I've not read any email
was older than a week I just do mark all
as red and stick him in an archive
folder I forget about them
if someone's eating out with me
something important and it's that
important they're gonna get in touch
with me again so I must have made my own
you know I'm the way I handle email he's
dreadful and I'm not gonna say that I'm
oh because I'm not but when you have
about 10,000 unread emails in your inbox
I sent a Matt a lot of email for some
reason it gets quite intimidating to
have to deal with that so I just
regularly declare bankruptcy on it and
just move stuff into an archive folder
and it makes me feel better that's
probably not the best way of doing it
has any productivity experts in the room
you probably might turn any cones of the
that's curling your toes at the force of
that focus in apps these are brilliant
these are you install them so I use one
on the Mac called focus or blocked by
focus there's versions on Windows as
well and what this will do is it lets
you even whitelist or blacklisted
science so I get the sudden out or I'm
working you know on my desktop computers
suddenly go to Facebook you'll just
it'll it will basically block you and
give you a nice little inspirational
quotes instead which is quite good to
disable it you normally have to put in a
load of admin credentials to do it so
you have to go through a few steps to
disable it if you want you know turn it
off during a certain time window but
again you know when you're trying to
limit your use of social media Facebook
and Twitter actually having a tool that
will stop you from using it when you're
trying supposed to be working it's quite
useful and there are some times that I
do need to go or mainly do need to
override it it's not it's not perfect
but Germany just stops you from you know
falling down a YouTube rabbit hole which
we all do already talked about this at
length some of us spend much more time
on it but removing social media from
your phone I know that sounds probably
terrifying to most people but try it why
don't you try it for like a week or two
weeks just remove all your social media
apps from your phone and see how you get
on see if you can break that habit of
constantly reaching down for your phone
makes a big difference and if you
commute to work on you know the bus or
the train or whatnot then delete these
app to take a book with you or take your
Kindle with you much better now music
musics a big one and there's a lot of
science around this I'm going to show
you some links to some academic papers
but music is scientifically proven to
help you focus if you listen to music
that you particularly like now for me I
can't listen to music that's got lyrics
in when I'm working because I find the
lyrics distracting so no-slip not for me
while I'm working I've slipped up
brilliant band so why I tend to listen
to these movie soundtracks you know
movie scores you know a big fan of like
Brian Tyler hands Emma and people like
that so I just have a 12 hour playlist
that I listen to and I just you know
shuffle that that helps me focus there's
quite a few studies so one from Applied
Economics in 1972
those doing repetitive tasks work more
efficiently when there's background
music I have a job when I was 16 I
worked in a cucumber packing Factory yes
you cucumbers come from somewhere so
I'll sit there for eight hours
cucumbers come down a production line
they get shrink-wrapped and then you get
a load of hot cucumber something coming
down a conveyor belt yet to pick them up
put them into a box
now they constantly have music playing
across speakers in the in the factory
row working because it helps make it
less menial you know you're sitting
there for eight hours doing that putting
cucumbers in a box paid surprisingly
well when you're 16 there you go this
one from the Journal of American Medical
Association again in 1972 so surgeons
are more accurate and efficient when
they operate with background music I
hope they're listening to classical
music if I go for an operation and
they've got Slipknot's latest album
playing as the as yeah anesthetics about
to take place only I'll be a little
worried so from the neuroscience
neuroscience and behavior physiology
place in 1999 said a study conducted to
correlate the number of identification
of and classical and classical or rock
music concluded that participants were
able to identify numbers faster and with
more accuracy whilst listening to music
this is about testing people's ability
to recall lists of numbers they sent
they're actually able to do it more
effectively when they had music playing
in the background again I think the type
of music is a probably important but
it's quite interesting nonetheless and
the last one so the Journal of
Psychology of music from 2005 say music
is proven to aid in positive moods
better quality of work and improved
efficiency so we've got kind of four you
know independent studies that were done
that kind of say the same thing music
helps you focus now I really want to
meet the person who invented noise
cancelling headphones and give them good
shake on the hands because what I think
I could get through life without their
paranoia canceling headphones so one
thing which is really good as well so if
you don't want to listen to specific
music but you just want a bit of noise
just you know help drown out the office
is absolutely so
I think this one's more easily is it
nicely okay there's lots of different
apps yeah basically you have lots of
different sounds like birds in a park
for city street and you can kind of mix
them a bit so you can create these a bit
about ambient back washes and that can
actually be surprisingly effective in
helping you concentrate there's a number
app called coffee tivity and if anyone's
ever heard of it coffee tivity it's an
app and it basically plays coffee shop
ambience now I have sat in Costa coffee
with my noise-canceling headphones on
listening to coffee and coffee shop
ambience from somewhere in Brazil and
the reason I've done that is especially
Christmas is right you know caustic
coffee starts playing Christmas music in
November what I don't wanna listen to
that so I listen to coffee shop ambience
from somewhere else in the world while
sitting in Custer coffee
I never said as normal perhaps like this
are surprisingly effective so if you
don't actually don't don't feeling the
mood to listen to music these apps are
surprisingly effective they're not very
expensive you can get them on my
iPhone's androids Mac Windows you see my
email number a top-level took the
screenshot at that time I had eleven
thousand one hundred and seventy four
emails and red lips at the last one then
so a change of scenery really helps you
to focus sometimes that could be a bit
hard if you're working in an office and
the expectations you go into the office
but you know maybe you could like you
know book out a meeting room and just go
work in the meeting room for an hour or
two I know quite even though I hire an
office you know I work from home Germany
one day a week sometimes twice if I've
got to do the school run with my wife's
away
co-working spaces I've got that four
different co-working spaces that I use
every now again so one in Nottingham
that was one in Darby one in Burton
which I go to sometimes just a little
day trip like an old man going out on
the day trip and these bus pass
yeah it's about going somewhere else
every now and again it just helps kind
of revitalize you focus a bit because
you're in a new environment
nobo is pretty well
okay so I've bombarded you with stuff
for the last hour so let's do a quick
summary and then we'll try and get you
down to the lunch queue I recommend the
teriyaki beef if you like beef rights
where are we okay so we talked a bit
about procrastination and it's a evil
half-brother procrustean well you're
attending to work but I actually doing
the things you supposed to be doing
procrastination is a big problem Germany
is a fear of failure or you might be a
perfectionist and that's just kind of
debilitating if I'm actually getting
some work done so you spent a bit of
time talking about lats we spent quite a
lot of time talking about social media
addictive it was a problem I had with
Facebook I know lots of people are
addicted to social media they may not
admit it but you know someone these
constantly pulling their phone out and
looking at what's happening on Twitter
or Instagram
you're probably addicted to social media
and you know I'm not saying you should
get rid of social media that's not
realistic but you know thinking about
how you're gonna handle your usage of
social media making some changes
actually removes the amount of
connections you have on there you know
it's not being horrible to the people
you're removing it's just controlling
you know what you have this ability to
is vitally important especially if
anyone you know is a parent or guardian
of children I mean we have to think
really carefully about this the current
generation growing up don't know a world
without social media in the Internet's
there are some of us probably remember
you know when the internet you got to
dial up and you have my dad shouting up
the stairs at me because the phone bill
would just come in kids don't know that
this is just the internet and social
media is there it's like running water
it's like gas coming into the house so
thinking about how you limit their
access to it without banning them from
doing it they need to learn how to use
these tools but you also need to control
as parents or guardians how much time
they spend on them I think that's
vitally important you're saying that me
and my wife have you know worried quite
a lot about now we talked a little bit
about sort of self motivation as well
about you know how it's important to try
and get into a mindset of only worrying
about the things that you actually have
control of in your life some things you
can't control so I don't worry about
them if you can't control or influence
something just don't waste the
brainpower on it focus on the things
that you do have a you know
to control over know this is why we
started earlier you know that the quote
from A Tale of Two Cities
you know I strongly believe you know
this book is it's a very old book but
that opening to that book is so relevant
to our modern day and age best of time
to the amount of tech don't you know all
the technical tools we have available to
us now there's a new JavaScript library
released every 14 seconds it seems
brilliant if you're into that so worst
of times because you know technology can
distract us
you know we've got constant barrage of
you know good TV on Netflix Amazon Prime
and services like that
Disney Plus comes to this country next
month well no March so I'll be watching
the mandalorian I'm happy to admit it
you know so we have to get control over
this it's very easy to get distracted
you know I think it's so much more on
its own you know spent in glass now
we're talking about it it's important to
think about how how you interact with
technology do you feel you've got the
balance right you know we're all
technologists probably software
developers but have you got that balance
right in your life because the one thing
you cannot control is a part in your
time you know we're only here for a
finite number of years you know you're
gonna have things you're gonna want to
achieve both professionally and
personally put the emphasis on those and
don't let the meaningful things distract
you from your life but the meaningless
things distract you from your life so
that's a fundamental mistake to make
okay so I've got a few resources that
may help I've written a book called
beating procrastination and getting
focused if you are on parole site I've
got a version of that as of course
called increasing productivity by
beating procrastination and a deep dives
a lot deeper into kind of the effects of
procrastination how you can get focused
in your life just recently release
another book as well called the art of
conversation and this is about how
people who might be more socially
anxious can improve their communication
skills with other people so you just
know I'm an introvert I find it hard to
talk to people sometimes I don't know
you know if I'm at a party or whatnot
I'm not I'm not the natural outgoing
person to go talk to someone quite happy
to stand on stage and talk to you but
you know having those kind
ad hoc conversations like a lot of
people can be hard so that's kind of
saying that I've written about in this
book it kind of works as a good
conference Survival Guide as well about
how you can sort of interact with people
on a more personal level so with that
thank you very much if you do want to
follow me and I'm on the dumpster fire
of hate at that address
thank you very much um if you could all
remember to vote as well that'd be great
the only cards at work are the green
ones the yellow and red cards are
commonly broken